well well well reject nation how you
doing so
more updates on the will smith slap her
around the world
we're here to tell you that chris rock
has sold out all the shows posting all
the academy awards to come doing great
man if it wasn't for that slapped it
wouldn't be sonali he might have but you
know now it's for official thank heavens
for the slapping but then uh after that
you know i was getting some
notifications and apparently will smith
himself has resigned from the academy
awards he has a statement that we
haven't read yet because why would we
unless there's a camera here and i got
some thoughts thoughts just don't stop
everywhere i go i'm having a
conversation about this and thoughts
just keep developing
left and right so let's hear what he has
to say here and talk about it let me
pull it up okay so we're reading from
deadline i have directly responded
to the academy's disciplinary hearing
notice
and big willy will fully accept any and
all consequences for my conduct good yes
my actions at the 94th academy awards
presentation were shocking painful and
inexcusable completely unjiggy not shaky
we were not jiggy with it that day
and no there is no excuse for it the
list of those i have hurt is long and
includes chris his family many of my
dear friends and loved ones and all
those in attendance and global audiences
at home it's true like i missed like the
first half hour of the oscars and i went
back and watched it i was like man there
are some funny bits from there that i'm
like no one talks about it will never be
spoken of again and a bunch of award
winners too i betrayed the trust of the
academy i deprived other nominees and
winners
of their opportunity to celebrate and be
celebrated for their extraordinary work
i am heartbroken i want to put the focus
back on those who deserve attention for
their achievements and follow the
academy to get back to the incredible
work it does to support creativity and
artists in film artistry and film i was
thinking about that because normally you
have the actor returned the following
year to present best actress that would
just be like all the talk again
it would be controversial like should
they have let him come back they
shouldn't have let him come back you
know like depending on what he would do
between now and then a year from now i
would be surprised that they brought him
back so i am resigning from membership
in the academy of motion picture arts
and sciences and will accept any further
consequences the board deems appropriate
jail jail and not giving my oscar back
right now
melted down and i wear it everywhere i
go i don't think he should give his
oscar back i mean there's something to
be said though with him like should he
have stayed should they have let him
give a speech i leaned towards the side
of now they should have asked him to
leave however still like it was so
fascinating watching the speech i i
preferred the show entertainment value
with the speech
human show at that point yeah but
morally probably should not have gone
change takes time and i am committed to
doing the work to ensure that i never
again allow violence to overtake
reason
this is the second record slap you
slapped a reporter once remember that
that can't slap that guy i do think that
this is probably the wisest decision it
would never stop being discussed we
don't know all the behind the scenes
logistics of what's going on here like
hey if you don't willfully resign
so and so might happen this might happen
this might happen perhaps like i do
think honestly when i heard i thought
like this is probably the best decision
actually moving forward right now like
could there be a moment in time where
he's forgiven by the public forgiven by
the people you know like he's really
shown development it seems like we
forgive celebrities incredibly fast what
will that scale be measured out on who
knows time will only tell what what it
really is that will allow us to be like
yeah you know what he's let's give him a
second shot at being accepted back in
here he was amazing and men in black
four absolutely she hadn't been oscar
nominated let's make it happen however i
do think this is the the smartest
decision like you this is the only thing
people have been talking about like all
week
yeah i mean this will at least lay some
of the you know back and forth animosity
to the rest and i really feel like if he
does hope to eventually maybe re-enter
the academy one day this is the way to
start the road to that recovery because
if he accepts responsibility now walks
away i feel like in five years time
unless there's some kind of rule within
where if you resign you can never come
back i feel like there's a road for him
if he stays on the straight and narrow
to be reinstated at some point
especially if he comes back around with
another amazing performance that sways
public opinion back in that direction or
whatever it might be and pending what
chris rock has to say on the subject
later on like i feel like there's still
a lot of moving parts and this is only
for right now that's well said
especially on what chris rock has to say
like as much as he's like sold out and
stuff he's able to do his show there's a
lot he said himself recently that he's
still processing everything that
happened what i was thinking about is
just really how sad all this is like
this is really sad this is his biggest
moment as an actor maybe not biggest box
office or something of that degree but
the highest award best recognition you
could ever get is receiving an oscar for
leading actor if that is your field so
this was supposed to be his greatest
night and his whole career
and then he blew it he blew it by going
up on stage reacting in anger slapping
uh not just a presenter but a friend
supposedly a friend supposed you know
it's usually like you think of movies
that are like rise and downfall and and
then here it's it is like a scarface
tale it's more than just one story
not only was it the greatest achievement
of his night but also a potential
downfall for the rest of will smith's
career like i do i really believe it
will be his you know like i said we seem
to forgive celebrities really fast this
is on a different scale though it's not
some like leaked audio tape a lot of us
experience this in real time so we got
to experience the shock worldwide you
know as opposed to did you hear about
what this guy did and then you listen to
it you're like let me make an assessment
about it it's different when you're like
experiencing it in real time and then
more and more celebrities keep coming
out like talking about it talking about
it talking about it and just keeping it
more and more condemned you know also
for like the safety of his family it's
probably best he just
hides like this is supposed to be his
greatest week and it's just turned into
because he
the thing that always that really struck
me as odd that night the first thing
that struck me as odd was nothing
happened to him that was the
weirdest part first thing i talked about
was
nothing happened well the academy still
cannot get straight the story as to
whether they asked him to leave whether
he was told to stay whether chris rock
was involved at all in that situation
like nobody can get the story straight
on how they wanted to handle it i feel
like there are probably two breathing a
sigh of relief going he's just handled
it for us the bottom line is things have
to change a lot of people go to the past
like even myself like guys do you
remember when quentin tarantino spit on
a reporter at the red carpet of the
oscars
do you know that do you remember that it
happened
no repercussions were made freaky
christian bail went ballistic on set at
a dp for getting in the way and
distracting for his performance almost
attacked the guy ends up but people held
him back he was an oscar a short time
later there's a lot of like
people who've done
bad things who are then either there or
rewarded but that is no excuse so we
have to start drawing the line basically
as i'm trying to say i'm not saying that
to say like nothing happened to them so
why should something happen yeah i'm
saying because nothing happened to them
on that regard those are different
scales there's different ways to measure
it out like i don't think the christian
bale incident is necessarily applicable
to the oscars
you know spit his
foot out
but i think you know like we have to
draw the line we can't just he can't go
walk away from this with no
repercussions and hold that line to
people in the future should anything
like that happen again especially you
know in a post kanye taylor swift world
i feel like we should have already
probably been doing that if connie did
this don't be surprised no i didn't know
he would just be memeing and encouraging
it further yeah we'll see what the
journey of will smith will ultimately be
he'll make a movie about this i think
why it's also painful for people is like
for myself especially like why it's
shocking is because will smith as an
individual is someone i've looked up to
for many years before we even started
doing youtube there was this compilation
called the philosophy of will smith that
i listened to over and over again to be
like a motivational speaker it seemed
like when he retired he could be a
motivational speaker to have such an
incident like this happen it's not just
shocking it's really disappointing
and i think that level of disappointment
and the per person that we believe will
smith to be a lot of us did at least it
hits way worse that's why i'm saying if
like it's not necessarily an insult to
kanye even though it can be
but will smith is much more of a
discernible role model for people
whereas you know kanye isn't i mean he
sure wants to be but isn't trying to
fill that mold as actively i'm not
trying to make this a race thing if mel
gibson did it
all right guys well what do you think
was this the right move leave your
thoughts down below i'll talk to you
guys soon
[Music]